what do you think of Anthony Lee yeah
like what do you think about loaded
question like let's say he passed away
oh and now there's no repercussions for
what you say how do you feel about him I
think he's really talented and really
funny you think so no but go ahead I
don't think so you guys don't think he's
talented we don't like him
straight up the joke when he's here we
make him not cool because everywhere
else he's like the man yeah he's the
only person that does it is oh really
it's just me really
I honestly think he does because he's
such a cool guy he's been on TV he's
like head of this big dance company you
know how like some bosses they like ball
gags anyway yeah yeah
I think that's him here and he says some
of the loser is that I'm like don't
reveal that
like sort of like a wall to really get
to know him you should talk some to
him next time
I probably